đến mộm gơ những con đường chính đạo giám sưng lại đến thành cuộc giữa hành tự nhiên khi hàng trực trụ của đó đồng loạt biến ra biển.
Hóan đạo nhỏ dưới Ấn độ dương gần tất liền Australia và đạo Zaba của Indonesia là nhà của hơn 2-3 trụ của đó.
Mỗi năm khi những cân mưa đầu tiên chút xuống một lửa trong suốt đó sẽ dự dương biến ra bởi vì anh để xin sản.
Cuộc giữa hành động bắt đầu vào khoảng tháng người tháng người mốt, những đôi khi có thể mộn đến vào tháng 12 hóa tháng 1.
Sáng sớm và triệu mộn là lúc những con cô được giận đoàn biến về biển.
Đến nơi chúng đau hàng để cô kể đại trứng mối con có thể mang tới 1 trong đàn trứng.
Sao chính này, những con con nôn trở lại đất liền.
Tại đó, chúng anh mình trong các mọng đá và mạnh dự xuất bán năm đầu đời.
Phần lớn ớt chung có thể bị cá nhỏ, cá đui mang ta và cá mập poài ăn thiệt.
Tuy nhiên, mộ thoại hai lần trong tập kì, số lượng con nôn sống xuất đủ lớn để vui chỉ và làm mới quần thể của đó trên đạo.